In the previous algorithm you've seen how many elements match a condition but
we didn't get to see any of the elements that match. Let's start modestly and
say we want to see the first one. That's a match. So here in our series of
pictures we just want to find the first one that is a portrait which I guess
here just happens to be this one. The difficulty with this algorithm is that we
don't really want to look at all of the elements, we want to stop as soon as we
have found one. Let's set a Boolean variable. We'll keep looking while we
haven't found a match. If the ith element matches, then we set found to true,
and otherwise, we increment i. We still need to be clear about what i is. i
should start at zero, and of course i shouldn't get too large. It needs to be
less than the size of the collection. Now when we terminated this loop there
are two possibilities. Maybe there wasn't any match in there at all. You could
imagine a picture gallery only with landscapes. But if there was at least one
match, then i is the index of that match. Once again it's your turn. Draw the
first portrait in the gallery.